continuamos con el análisis del discurso
de Joe biden en su discurso del estado
de la unión y para ello mi compañero
Juan Pablo lucumí ha preparado su
segmento de economía Juan Pablo Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela vamos a
empezar hablando de los temas económicos
a los que se refirió biden anoche en
este discurso crucial de Cara a las
presidenciales del 2024 Así es Ángela y
si hay un mensaje Claro que dejó el
presidente biden a los republicanos fue
la frase terminemos el trabajo la cual
repitió una y otra vez según él se debe
trabajar en conjunto para reconstruir la
economía unir el país y terminar muchos
de los proyectos que ya se han llevado a
cabo que ya se han iniciado vayan
arremetió contra las grandes empresas
petroleras que en medio del
encarecimiento de los precios de los
combustibles pues las acusa de tener
monumentales ganancias y poca inversión
en producción para intentar regular los
precios no es la primera vez que las
acusa ya vamos a escuchar como las
criticó a las petroleras Pero antes me
gustaría me gustaría leerle lo que dijo
el mandatario respecto a la inflación
dijo lo siguiente la inflación de los
alimentos está bajando no lo
suficientemente rápido pero está bajando
la inflación ha caído todos los meses
Durante los últimos seis meses Mientras
que el salario neto ha aumentado pero
estamos mejor posicionados que cualquier
país en la tierra en este momento Ahora
sí escuchemos al mandatario
[Aplausos]
el hecho de que en 2020 55 de las
corporaciones más grandes de Estados
Unidos obtuvieran 40 mil millones de
dólares en ganancias y pagarán cero
impuestos federales 0 amigos Simplemente
no es justo bajo mis planes y mientras
yo sea presidente nadie que gane menos
de 400 mil dólares pagará un centavo
pero ningún multimillonario debería
pagar una tasa impositiva más baja que
un maestro de escuela o un bombero
y a otro de los que el presidente
estadounidense señaló fue a los
multimillonarios subjetivo es poner un
impuesto para grabar las ganancias de
capital no realizadas de activos como
acciones bonos o empresas privadas de
personas de alto poder adquisitivo
escuchemos
han notado Que las grandes petroleras
acaban de informar sus ganancias
ganancias récord el año pasado ganaron
200 mil millones de en medio de una
crisis energética mundial creo que es
indignante por qué Pues porque
invirtieron muy poco de esa ganancia en
una mayor producción nacional hubieran
podido invertir en producción para
mantener bajos los precios de la
gasolina pero en lugar de eso usaron las
ganancias récord para recuperar sus
propias acciones vamos a pasar a otros
temas en Argentina el gobierno acaba de
cerrar un acuerdo que impulsa el sector
de Tecnológico del país Ángela un
acuerdo que se hizo con el banco
interamericano de desarrollo se trata de
un préstamo de 80 millones de dólares
para el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
que estará destinado para la innovación
y transformación digital de las micro
pequeñas y medianas empresas Este
programa incluye acompañamiento técnico
y tecnológico que ayude a las empresas a
adaptarse a una economía baja en
emisiones y resiliente impactos del
cambio climático el ministro de economía
Sergio massa dijo que Argentina terminó
el 2022 con un récord histórico de
desembolsos de organismos
internacionales de crédito para
proyectos de desarrollo esto por
5023 millones de dólares esperemos Pues
que toda esta plata sea reflejada en
estos proyectos Pues ojalá que sí Juan
Pablo vamos a pasar ahora a Australia
que por otro lado rechazó un mega a
proyecto de una mina de Carbón algo que
hizo Aparentemente en defensa del medio
ambiente Así es Ángela se trata de un
proyecto impulsado por un
multimillonario local nacional en el que
se proyectaba a construir dos Minas a
cielo abierto que operarían durante 20
años explotarían cerca de 10 millones de
toneladas de Carbón cada año en palabras
de la ministra de ambiente y agua abro
comillas las repercusiones negativas
para el medio ambiente son demasiado
grandes la mina está a cielo abierto a
menos de 10 kilómetros de la gran
Barrera de arrecifes y el riesgo de
contaminación y daños es irreversibles
es muy real cierro comillas y es que con
la mina pondrían en peligro las aguas
subterráneas
riachuelos pastizales marinos además de
los animales que habitan en la zona Esta
es la primera vez que Australia rechaza
un proyecto de explotación de carbón
amparados en la ley ambiental del país
oceánico y hace parte de una promesa del
gobierno laborista de Anthony alvanici
de luchar contra el cambio climático y
proteger el medio ambiente y además que
cuantos esfuerzos se han hecho por
proteger la gran Barrera de coral que
entre otras está muy blanqueada en
Muchas de sus zonas ahora más en Asia El
Banco Central de la India subió este
miércoles sus tasas de interés
nuevamente un movimiento de este tipo
así es lo hemos venido reportando en
diferentes ocasiones y hay una subida de
los tipos Pero esto es en menor aumento
es el menor aumento desde mayo El Banco
Central de la quinta Economía del mundo
subió 25 puntos básicos su tasa de
referencia dejándola hasta el
6,5%, la desaceleración en el incremento
de los precios responde a que los
aumentos previos se han visto reflejados
en una disminución de la inflación la
cual se ubicó en
5,72% interanual
ha ido bajando y Por ende pues la
desaceleración en las tasas de interés y
para finalizar su cifra del día con una
noticia que le da entrada a nuestros
invidentes segmento de directo América
Así es le da la entrada a los deportes y
es
10.941 dólares lo que ha ganado Lebron
James por cada punto que ha anotado para
un salario total de 420 millones hasta
la mitad de su vigésima temporada en la
NBA un dato que damos hoy justo cuando
se convirtió en el máximo anotador de
todos los tiempos en la NBA Pero lo
dejamos ahí porque ya viene Luis Méndez
con más Ahora nos volvemos con más
economía